(Applause.)
HAASS: Well, good afternoon.
I'm Richard Haass, and I want to welcome everyone
in the room and watching from afar to the
Council on Foreign Relations.
And today we are fortunate and honored to
have with us the 25th secretary of defense-or,
if you prefer, SecDef of the United States,
Ashton Carter.
Now, I realize ours is a country of about
320 million people, but if there ever was
one person meant to be secretary of defense,
it is Ash.
(Laughter.)
He is the consummate scholar practitioner.
He's held any number of influential positions
in the five-sided building, including that
of deputy secretary.
But beyond that, he has degrees in medieval
history and theoretical physics.
I find it difficult to think of a better preparation-(laughter)-oh,
you don't even know what I'm going to say.
(Laughter.)
I find it hard to think of a better preparation
for understanding what is happening or could
come to happen in today's Middle East.
He's about to take off-probably not on JetBlue-for
India and the Philippines, and that's a very
good thing.
The Asia-Pacific region is the part of the
world where a lot of this century's history
will be written.
Now, I understand the Middle East gets the
lion's share of the headlines, but time spent
in the Far East is time well spent.
It's essential that the urgent now crowd out
the important.
Full disclosure: Ash and I have been friends
and colleagues for over three decades now.
We first got to know each other well in the
1980s when we were both faculty at Harvard's
Kennedy School.
One way of another, though, that collaboration
was destined to end in 1989 as either he was
heading off for a big job in the Dukakis administration
or I was going to work for then-Vice President
George H.W.
Bush.
The rest, as they say, is history.
(Laughter.)
Today's meeting will begin with Secretary
Carter delivering extensive remarks on the
Asia-Pacific.
This will then be followed by a conversation
between the secretary and Mary Boies, who
is, among other things, not just a prominent
lawyer but also a member of our board of directors
and someone with extensive knowledge of and
experience with the U.S. military.
Then the secretary will take a few questions,
after Mary, from you, our members.
The plan is to wrap up by about 3:15 or, as
the secretary likes to call it, 15:15.
With that, Secretary Carter.
(Applause.)
CARTER: Well, good afternoon, everyone.
And, Richard, thanks.
Thanks so much for those words, for decades
of friendship, for your leadership here at
the Council, and above all for your public
service, which continues.
Richard is a member of the Department of Defense's
Defense Policy Board.
We count on him for advice on all subjects
all the time.
He and I were just talking shortly before
this about some things that he's preparing
to give us some advice on in just a few weeks'
time.
It's nice to see a lot of old friends here
at the Council, many of you.
I looked at the list of attendees coming and
it was like a homecoming in many, many ways-great
to visit all my friends and be here at the
Council, because for generations the Council's
hosted the debates and supported the thinkers
and ideas that have shaped America's relationship
with the world, and those ideas are as important
as ever as we enter a new strategic era.
Indeed, today's security environment is dramatically
different from the one that we have had for
the last 25 years.
In this era we face no fewer than five evolving
major immediate challenges: countering the
prospect of Russian aggression and coercion,
especially in Europe; managing historic change
in the vital Asia-Pacific region, including
China's rise, which we welcome, and some of
its actions, such as in the South China Sea,
about which we share the serious concerns
of all in the region; strengthening our deterrent
and defense forces in the fact of North Korea's
continued nuclear pursuits and provocations;
checking Iranian aggression and malign influence
in the Gulf; and protecting our friends and
allies, especially Israel; and accelerating
the defeat of ISIL and its parent tumor in
Iraq and Syria and everywhere it's metastasizing
around the world, as well as protecting our
people here in the homeland.
The United States and the Department of Defense
must and will address all five of those challenges.
To do so is going to require some new strategic
and operational approaches, new force posture
in many places, and large investments in new
and enhanced capabilities-and all this we're
doing.
But today I want to talk to you about how
we're meeting the challenges and seizing the
opportunities in the Asia-Pacific, and in
particular our growing security network there.
Almost all the nations there are asking us
to do more with them, bilaterally and multilaterally.
Tomorrow, as Richard said, I leave for India
and the Philippines, and I'm going to highlight
today some of the advances we'll be announcing
along the way.
The Asia-Pacific is-and Richard made this
point-the single-most consequential region
of the world for America's future.
We have long played an essential and pivotal
role in that region, and we're working today
both individually and with our allies and
partners to ensure the Asia-Pacific remains
a region where everyone-everyone can rise
and prosper.
That has been America's objective and practice
for decades.
Regardless of what else was going on at home
or in other parts of the world, during Democratic
and Republican administrations, in times of
surplus and deficit, war and peace, the United
States has played a pivotal role economically,
politically, and militarily in the Asia-Pacific.
Along with a wide variety of allies and partners,
for decades we have stood tall for enduring
principles, including peaceful resolution
of disputes, the freedom of navigation and
overflight.
We've helped ensure that countries can make
their own security and economic choices, free
from coercion and intimidation.
And we have promoted free trade and the rule
of law to support development and unprecedented
growth.
Of course, fundamentally sustaining this human
progress requires, as a foundation, security
and stability, and the United States has helped
provide both with its strong defense engagement
in the region.
The highly capable men and women of the America
armed forces and our unique technology and
assets, coupled to our values, have long provided
the necessary reassurance-an attractive and
appealing reassurance-and worked to keep the
peace in the Asia-Pacific.
And because we have done so inclusively and
in a principled and respectful way, we have
developed alliances and partnerships all over
the region.
These relationships, nurtured over decades,
tested in crisis and built on shared interests,
values, and sacrifice, form the bedrock of
our role in the Asia-Pacific, and accordingly
its stability and prosperity.
The results have been extraordinary in the
interests of and to the benefit of all nations,
including the United States.
Since World War II, millions have been lifted
from poverty and into the middle class.
And even though there's still room for improvement,
democracy and freedom have spread to places
across the region, and economic miracle after
economic miracle has occurred in the region,
first in Japan.
Then Taiwan, South Korea, Southeast Asia rose
and prospered.
And now today China and India are doing the
same.
This progress creates opportunities for the
region to continue to grow, but of course
dramatic change can also produce some negatives,
and recently not all the news out of the Asia-Pacific
has been positive.
Indeed, in the South China Sea, China's actions
in particular are raising regional tensions.
That's why countries across the Asia-Pacific
are voicing concern with militarization, and
especially over the last year with China's
actions, which stand out in size and scope.
They're voicing those concerns publicly and
privately at the highest levels in regional
meetings and global fora.
That's why many of these countries are reaching
out anew to the United States to uphold the
rules and the principles that have allowed
the region to thrive.
That's why we support intensified regional
diplomacy, not increased tensions, the threat
of force, or unilateral changes to the status
quo.
And that's one reason why we're making enormous
investments in our capabilities, why so many
are asking us to do more with them, and why
we'll continue to fly and sail and operate
wherever international law allows, because
we must continue the progress that has helped
so many in the region to rise and prosper.
President Obama launched the rebalance to
Asia-Pacific to ensure that we do our part
to make that bright opportunity come to pass.
While I've, of course, absorbed myself with
the defense component of the rebalance, I
should be clear that one of the most important
strategic parts of the rebalance is the Trans-Pacific
Partnership trade pact.
TPP will bind the United States more closely
together with 11 other economies and unlock
economic opportunities for the United States
and many of its allies and partners.
And TPP will help reinforce the open and inclusive
economic approach that has benefited so many
in the Asia-Pacific.
TPP should be ratified because of its economic
and strategic benefits and because we must
recognize what the alternative to TPP really
is-a regional economy, largest in the world,
with standards that don't serve American interests
and one that's carved up by lopsided, coercively
negotiated, lower-standard deals.
That's why I've said that TPP is as strategically
important to the rebalance as an aircraft
carrier.
And I strongly urge Congress to approve TPP
this year.
Militarily, the Department of Defense is operationalizing
the next phase of the rebalance and cementing
it for the long term.
We're enhancing America's force posture throughout
this vitally important region to continue
playing a pivotal role from the sea and the
air and under the water, as well as to make
our posture more geographically distributed,
more operationally resilient, and more politically
sustainable.
To do so, we continue to bring the best people
and platforms forward to the Asia-Pacific,
not only increasing the number of U.S. military
personnel in the region, part of some 365,000
assigned to the Asia-Pacific today, but also
sending and stationing some of our most advanced
capabilities there.
That includes F-22 and F-35 stealth fighter
jets, P-8 Poseidon maritime surveillance aircraft,
continuous deployments of B-2 and B-52 strategic
bombers, and also our newest surface warfare
ships like the amphibious assault ship USS
America and all three of our newest class
of stealth destroyers, the DDG-1000, which
will be all home-ported with the Pacific Fleet.
And all the while we're bringing America's
regional force posture into the 21st century
by rotating American personnel into new and
more places like northern Australia and new
sites in the Philippines and modernizing our
existing footprint in Japan and the Republic
of Korea.
How we're doing this is a reflection of a
shift we're making across the Army, the Navy,
the Air Force, and the Marine Corps after
15 years of intensive effort in counterinsurgency
in Iraq and Afghanistan toward full-spectrum
operations.
And in our 2017 defense budget, which I've
presented to Congress over the past few weeks,
we're making investments critical to the rebalance.
One is our surface fleet, which under our
budget grows both the number of ships and,
importantly, above all, their capabilities
to deter and, if deterrence fails, defeat
even the most advanced potential naval adversaries
and protect the maritime security we all depend
on.
Just one new example of how we're making our
ships' capabilities increasingly lethal is
by maximizing production of the SM-6 missile,
one of our most modern and capable munitions,
which now has a brand new anti-ship capability.
And I could go on.
We're also investing to ensure our continued
air superiority and global reach, including
with over $12 billion for the new B-21 long-range
strike bomber.
Another investment is in undersea capabilities,
where we continue to dominate and where we're
investing over $8 billion just next year to
ensure ours is the most lethal and most advanced
undersea and anti-submarine force in the world.
That includes new undersea drones in multiple
sizes and diverse payloads that can importantly
operate in shallow waters, where manned submarines
can't.
We're also making large new investments in
cyber, in electronic warfare, space capabilities,
a total of $34 billion just next year.
Among other things, this will help us build
our cyber-mission force, develop next-generation
electronic jammers, and prepare for the possibility
of a conflict that extends into space.
And more is coming, including some surprises.
(Scattered laughter.)
We're also strengthening our alliances and
partnerships, which will be the focus of my
trip this coming week.
And in that regard, let me take you on a brief
tour of what we're doing with partners around
the region and then focus on India and the
Philippines, where I'll be traveling next
week, and important advances are being made
that occasion my trip.
Our alliances and partnerships are and will
remain one of our most important strategic
assets.
Our allies around the world, including those
in the Asia-Pacific, have stood with us and
fought with us time and again, most recently
in Iraq, Afghanistan, and against ISIL.
And we're just as committed to them.
As history has shown, we've fought with our
friends and allies and to defend the principles
and values we share in the Asia-Pacific, in
Europe, in the Middle East, and elsewhere.
And while I can't take the time to detail
it today, both Japan and the Republic of Korea
are strengthening their own militaries and
changing how they operate within our alliances
in fundamental and forward-looking ways.
We're sharing our best and newest capabilities,
including the F-35 Joint Strike Fighter, which
will soon begin to operate with both Japan
and the Republic of Korea.
Meanwhile, we're developing newer partnerships
with Vietnam, with Malaysia, with Indonesia,
and others, while also enhancing our already
high-performing relationship with Singapore.
And we're holding more numerous and more sophisticated
exercises with a growing network of partner
countries, none larger than this summer's
RIMPAC, which will bring together more than
two dozen navies, nearly twice the number
that participated just six years ago, to develop
the relationships that are critical to ensuring
the safety and security and peace of the region's
sea lanes.
You can see the breadth and depth of our bilateral
efforts with one of our key growing partners,
India, where I'll arrive a short time from
right now.
The U.S.-India relationship is destined to
be one of the most significant partnerships
of the 21st century.
Ours are two great nations that share a great
deal-democratic governments, multiethnic and
multicultural societies with a commitment
to individual freedom and inclusivity, and
growing, innovative, open economies.
Over the course of my years at the Defense
Department, I've seen a remarkable convergence
of U.S. and Indian interests, what I call
a strategic handshake.
As the United States is reaching west in its
rebalance, India is reaching east in Prime
Minister Modi's Act East policy that will
bring it farther into the Indian and Pacific
Oceans.
We see this handshake reflected in the Joint
Strategic Vision Statement that President
Obama and Prime Minister Modi released last
January and the 2015 framework for the U.S.-India
defense relationship, also a new thing, which
Indian Defense Minister Parrikar and I signed
last year in Delhi.
The defense framework is foundational, and
it's going to guide the U.S.-India defense
relationship for the next decade.
And there's another handshake between our
countries as well, a technological one.
In 2012 the United States and India created
the Defense Technology and Trade Initiative
to leverage the convergence between our industrial
and technological abilities in an unprecedented
way, this after a half a century since Indian
independence of separation of our militaries
and our industrial systems.
That initiative grasps hands with Prime Minister
Modi's Make in India campaign to expand the
nation's industrial and defense base.
And it will lead to greater production-co-production,
excuse me-and co-development of defense capabilities.
While in India, I'll meet with Prime Minister
Modi and also Defense Minister Parrikar to
discuss the progress we've made together in
aircraft-carrier, jet-fighter, and jet-engine
collaboration.
And we'll talk about exciting new projects,
the details of which I can't go into this
afternoon, but stay tuned when I'm with Minister
Parrikar.
There's so much potential here, which is why
we're seizing every opportunity we can.
Last year the Modi government reached out
to the United States to discuss the possibility
of launching joint production on a new platform
to build on the work Lockheed Martin and Indian
industry achieved on the C-130J project, and
what Boeing and Indian industry will achieve
in the production of Apache and Chinook helicopters
in India, recently purchased.
Members of my team and industry are right
now, as we are here in New York, in India
looking at the potential co-production of
fighter aircraft.
These conversations represent the growing
enthusiasm of U.S.-India partnership.
And even more than that, its promise.
While these negotiations can be difficult,
and global competition is high, I have no
doubt that in the coming years the United
States and India will embark on a landmark
co-production agreement that will bring our
two countries closer together and make our
militaries stronger.
As our strategic and technological interests
are drawn together, so too have our military
ties.
We're coming together operationally across
domains by air, land, and sea, to collaborate
on humanitarian assistance, disaster relief,
maritime security, and maritime domain awareness.
This week will also conclude several important
agreements, including one on commercial shipping
information exchange, which will make many
new things possible in the future.
Our gathering partnership in defense can also
be seen in India's return to major joint exercises,
like Red Flag, our prestigious U.S. Air Force-hosted
aerial combat training exercise where all
our top pilots, and those from countries like
India, train together.
India will again participate in RIMPAC, which
I mentioned, the world's largest international
maritime exercise.
And in the Malabar exercise, Japan, India,
and the United States, all three, have operated
together at sea in such critical training
as air defense and anti-submarine warfare.
From India, I'll travel to the Philippines,
with which we have one of our longest relationships
in the region.
We share much history and many common ties
with the Philippines, and our long-running
defense alliance has been a cornerstone of
peace and stability in the region for more
than 65 years.
And as President Obama has made clear, our
commitment to the Philippines is ironclad.
Today our alliance is as close as it's been
in many years, thanks to two major recent
steps forward that occasion my visit in coming
days.
First is the U.S.-Philippines Enhanced Defense
Cooperation Agreement, the so-called EDCA,
which is a landmark agreement that was ratified
in the Philippines in January.
And also, the new U.S. Southeast Asia Maritime
Security Initiative, by which we-that is,
the Department of Defense-is helping to fund
these changes in the Philippines and other
partners in the region.
As part of EDCA's implementation, we're supporting
modernization of the Philippine armed forces,
and strengthening mutual defense, an arrangement
that will allow our forces, at the invitation
of the government of the Philippines, to conduct
regular rotational training exercises and
activities.
We recently announced an initial slate of
five agreed locations for those alliance activities.
Locations are arrayed throughout the archipelago.
They will offer the opportunity for increasingly
complex bilateral engagements.
And I plan to visit two of those locations
next week.
First, Fort Magsinghsingh (sic; Magsaysay)
and Antonio Bautista Air Force--saysay, I
should say-and Antonio Bautista Air Force
Base.
At Fort Magsaysay, the former home of the
Philippines army's premier training facility,
we previously made use of limited preposition
disaster relief supplies that supported our
response to Typhoon Haiyan in 2013.
EDCA will enable us to augment these stocks
and add new ones to the air base, thereby
improving our ability to respond to future
disasters.
I'll be discussing both of these things at
these sites when I arrive in the Philippines.
And last year, at the region's Shangri-La
Dialogue, I announced our Maritime Security
Initiative.
This initiative represents a $425 million,
five-year commitment by the Defense Department
to help countries like the Philippines share
information, identify potential threats, and
work collaboratively to address common challenges
in the region.
We've just released the first tranche of this
money, nearly 80 percent of which is going
to the Philippines.
There, it will help modernize the technology
and train the staff at the Philippines National
Coast Watch Center, enhance an information
network to enable the sharing of classified
communications between the U.S. Pacific Command
and Hawaii and key Philippine maritime command
centers, provide an aerostat reconnaissance
platform, and outfit the Philippine navy patrol
vessels with better sensors so they can do
more in the region's waters.
These two things, EDCA and the Maritime Security
Initiative, will take the U.S.-Philippines
alliance capability to a new level, one that
has not been seen in decades.
I will also see some of this first-hand at
Exercise Balikatan 2016, our premier exercise
with the Philippines.
Balikatan is going on right now, and includes
over 7,000 personnel from every military service
in both countries, dozens of American aircraft,
vehicles and vessels, including one of our
aircraft carriers and several important components,
including a simulated gas and oil platform
recovery raid in the South China Sea.
Balikatan signals shared resolve.
It enhances our shared capabilities.
And it demonstrates, once again, America's
dedication to standing shoulder-to-shoulder
with the Philippines.
Like our alliance with the Philippines and
our developing partnership with India, America's
bilateral relationships remain the bedrock
of our presence and engagement in the Asia-Pacific.
But in a large and interconnected region,
especially one with so many strong, capable,
and dedicated players, it makes sense to network
and link relationships and produce gains for
all.
And that's what we're doing.
Now, unlike-I mean-excuse me.
Unlike elsewhere in the world, peace and stability
in the Asia-Pacific has never been maintained
by a region-wide alliance, like NATO.
No comparable formal structure.
That's made sense for the Asia-Pacific, with
its unique history, geography, and politics.
Instead, regional security, stability, and
prosperity have required nations working together
less formally.
And the United States has been an important
builder, cement, and participant in this arrangement.
Today, as the region changes, the United States
is augmenting our bilateral relationships
and alliance with trilateral and multilateral
arrangements.
We're weaving these partnerships together
to more effectively bolster American and regional
security.
This network, with its shared values, habits
of cooperation, and compatible and complementary
capabilities, will expand the reach of all,
responsibly share the security burden, and
help ensure peace and stability in the region
for years to come.
This burgeoning networks builds in three ways.
First, the Department of Defense is strongly
emphasizing trilateral mechanisms to bring
together like-minded allies and partners to
maximize individual contributions to regional
peace and security, and link together nations
that previously worked with us mostly separately.
For example, the U.S.-Japan-Korea trilateral
partnership helps us all work together, as
well as share information and coordinate responses
to, for example, North Korean provocations.
Last month's trilateral meeting between President
Obama, Prime Minister Abe, and President Park
on this topic was historic.
The U.S.-Japan-Australia relationship is also
expanding practical cooperation, enhancing
exercises, training, and information sharing,
and building capabilities.
And our burgeoning U.S.-Japan-India trilateral
relationship is evolving from the strategic
dialogue, where it began, through joint activities,
like the Malabar Exercise, to real, practical
security cooperation that spans the entire
region, from the subcontinent right around
to East Asia.
Second, to improve regional security, we're
encouraging our allies and partners to actively
develop their own interconnected security
relationships.
Many countries within the Asia-Pacific are
strengthening their bilateral relationships
with one another in enhanced ways that we
think also enhance regional stability.
But they're also creating their own trilateral
arrangements.
The Japan-Australia-India trilateral meeting
last June, for example, was a welcome and
brand-new development.
Third, we're helping create an interconnected
regional architecture, from one end of the
region to another, through engagement and
activities in multilateral fora, such as the
ASEAN Defense Ministers Meeting.
In this way, the United States is helping
strengthen relationship and building partner
capabilities on key issues, like maritime
security, humanitarian assistance, and disaster
relief.
Singapore has shown great leadership in this
area by hosting an operations center to coordinate
activities across ASEAN.
It's important to remember that our bilateral,
trilateral, and multilateral relationships,
and the developing network they comprise,
is not aimed at any particular country.
Rather, it demonstrates that the region wants
cooperation, not coercion; and a continuation,
not an end, of decades of stability, peace,
and progress.
The network's not closed.
It excludes no one.
We want cooperation and shared leadership
so that other nations who want to contribute
to regional stability and security, they can
work with the other nations of the region
to do so.
For example-important example-we have disagreements
with China, but we are committed to working
through them in ways that do not destabilize
the region.
That's one reason why we will continue to
pursue a military-to-military relationship
with China, focused on risk reduction and
practical cooperation in areas of mutual interest.
This network overall demonstrates the United
States' commitment to remaining a pivotal
and essential leader in the Asia-Pacific for
decades to come.
By operationalizing the rebalance, by transforming
old alliances and new partnerships, and by
networking security, we can gather force and
respond to any manner of crisis, manmade or
natural disaster, and continue to promote
and defend the principles that have allowed
so many in the region to rise and prosper
for so long.
Let me close with a few words about who makes
that possible.
As I stand here, there are hundreds of thousands
of men and women serving and defending our
country-right now, in every time zone, every
domain, in the air, ashore, and afloat.
They are the ones who are operationalizing
the rebalance.
They're making the network work.
They need always to be in our minds.
You know, they say that security-frequently
this is said in this region-is like oxygen:
when you have enough of it, you pay no attention
to it; but when you don't have enough, you
can think of nothing else.
America's service members provide that oxygen-the
security that allows millions upon millions
of people, not just in America and not just
in the Asia-Pacific, but in so much of the
world to be safe, to raise their children,
to dream their dreams, to live lives that
are full.
Our soldiers, sailors, airmen, and Marines
take grave risks to provide that security,
and some make the ultimate sacrifice.
They do so not just because they were ordered
to, and they do so not only because they want
to protect their buddies.
They do so because they know that they help
make the world a better place through American
leadership.
In a new strategic era and at a time of great
change, we must and will continue to play
that essential, principled role in the Asia-Pacific.
We will work with new partners and old allies.
We'll network our security relationships.
We will invest and innovate.
We'll change how we plan, how we operate,
even how we fight.
But we will never change what we're willing
to fight for: for our safety and freedoms,
and that of our friends and allies; and for
the values, principles, and rule-based order
that produced security, stability, and prosperity
for all.
Because we do so, we will continue to ensure
that the Asia-Pacific remains a region where
everyone can rise and prosper for generations
to come.
Thank you.
(Applause.)
BOIES: Thank you, Mr. Secretary.
CARTER: Thank you, Mary.
BOIES: And welcome to everyone at the CFR
Corporate Conference.
You stated in the defense posture that was
released, I believe, last month that-and I'm
going to quote-"We expect China to uphold
President Xi's pledge not to pursue militarization
of the Spratly Islands of the South China
Sea."
There are reports of mounting evidence that
the Chinese are doing in the Scarborough Shoals
exactly what they were doing in the Spratly
Islands; that is, namely, building an island
around some kind of maritime feature or rock.
The shoals have-are also claimed by the Philippines,
who have brought an arbitration in The Hague.
The shoals are 140 miles off the coast of
Manila.
Has the president of China broken his pledge?
CARTER: Well, we'll see.
But the president of China did make that pledge.
But let me back up a little bit because the
South China Sea is a place that's very much
in the focus of many in the region, to which
I'll be traveling over the next few days.
China is one of many claimants to various
features throughout the region, many of which
have taken steps that we oppose, namely militarization.
But over the last year, the scale and scope,
as I indicated, of China's have been-have
outstripped anybody else's.
The United States' position on this is we
don't take any position on the claims themselves,
but we do take a position on militarization
by anyone, but especially by China in this
particular context.
It won't affect our operations, but it disquiets
the region when this occurs.
It has the effect of, of course, causing us
to react-which will be to-in the ways that
I described in terms of our own preparations-but
also of having what I also described, which
is many countries in the region want to work
with us more.
So that's the effect of this.
But, you know, our approach, Mary, is that
things in the South China Sea should be a
reflection of our overall approach to the
region, which is this is a region that has
had it good for 70 years, and this would be
a serious mistake for all of us to allow that
to unravel, and for militarization to lead
to tension to lead to conflict.
So we're trying to prevent that.
That's the position we come to this from,
and we certainly have been given to believe
that the president of China shares that view
and made that commitment.
But we'll see.
BOIES: Critics have argued that our response
has been rather weak.
We have done some freedom of navigation operations
within the 12-mile limit of features or islands
that China declares are theirs, but then we've
confused the issue by characterizing them
as innocent passage, which does not suggest
that we're disputing the ownership.
And we've had various of these operations,
and they don't seem to have a clear signal.
Is there a reason for that?
CARTER: Well, their purpose isn't to signal;
their purpose is they've been going on for
decades now, and we continue to do that.
There are differences between different kinds
of passage, as you indicate.
We know what we're doing.
But, I mean, the basic point here is that
the United States, here and everywhere around
the world-whether it's the Arctic, whether
it's the Horn of Africa-we, along with virtually
everyone else, insists upon freedom of navigation
consistent with international law.
So that's how we operate.
And you say, what are we doing more generally
in the region?
Well, and that's what I was describing there,
which is trying to work with others, to include
China-and that's an important point-to widen
the network of security cooperation in a region
where, remember, there is no NATO, where the
wounds of the past never healed.
And so it's important.
And the United States plays an important role,
both with respect to China, but also with
respect to Japan, South Korea, India.
I mean, just walk around.
And that's what we're doing there.
We're committed to that.
We've played that role for decades.
We want to keep a good thing going-we and
everybody else in the region.
BOIES: And there are many areas in which we
have found a lot of cooperation with China-
CARTER: Sure.
BOIES: -in areas of climate change; perhaps
in the areas of cyber-it's probably too early
to see there; certainly to an extent with
North Korea.
Although North Korea nonetheless still seems
to be persisting in developing its programs.
It did a nuclear warhead test in January,
more missile testing in February just of this
year.
And question there: Is our deterrence working?
It doesn't seem to be.
CARTER: Well, our deterrence of conflict has
worked for 60 years, and we continue to strengthen
that.
We have a slogan for U.S. Forces Korea, which
stand on the DMZ every day: "Fight tonight."
That's not that they want to fight tonight,
but they're ready to fight tonight.
That's why we're doing so much-and I won't
go into it here, but you can read about it-to
strengthen and transform the U.S.-ROK alliance
really in fundamental ways: its command and
control, its basic structure, its approach
to deterrence on the Korean Peninsula.
And that deterrence has been strong now for
50, 60 years.
We intend to keep it that way.
Now, it presents new challenges for deterrence
when the North Koreans build missiles and
test nuclear weapons.
And to get to your point about China, you
know, China has been a party to the talks
in which people in the region-not just us
but China also, South Korea, Japan, and also
Russia-have tried to get the North Koreans
to turn back.
China has, logically speaking, by far and
away the greatest leverage over North Korea
by dint of geographical proximity, economic
relations, and so forth.
They have been unsuccessful so far, and certainly
we have been unsuccessful in getting North
Korea to stop.
What that's causing us to do is we are reacting
in terms of how we're protecting ourselves,
our forces on the peninsula-that's what the
THAAD missile defense system is about on the
Korean Peninsula-and various changes we're
making to our defensive strategy and our deterrent
plans on the Korean Peninsula.
We don't like to have to be doing that, but
we're doing that and we have to do that, as
we have for decades, because we've got to
keep deterrence strong.
BOIES: You mentioned the THAAD system, the
Terminal High Altitude Defense system, and
that is an area where the Chinese now are
vigorously objecting should that system be
deployed in South Korea, which, at the present
time, it is not.
Tell us what the risks and benefits that you
see in that particular endeavor.
Is it going to happen or are we going to back
down?
CARTER: Oh, it's going to happen.
No, it's a necessary thing.
It's between us and South Korea.
It's part of protecting our own forces on
the Korean Peninsula and protecting South
Korea.
It has nothing to do with the Chinese.
And I do wish the Chinese would work with
us, or really work bilaterally with North
Korea more effectively-although it's easy
to say that but dealing with North Korea for
anybody is a challenge-at heading off their
missile challenge in the first place.
But we need to defend our own people.
We need to defend our own allies.
And we're going to do that.
BOIES: The Chinese ambassador to South Korea
said that should the THAAD missile system
be deployed in South Korea, that will-it was
translated "in an instant" end the good bilateral
relations that have been built up over at
least the last three years between China and
South Korea.
Is that just an idle threat?
CARTER: Well, that would be sort of illogical.
I can't speak for a Chinese ambassador, but
we're actually quite encouraged to see the
Republic of Korea and China strengthening
their own relationship.
That's had its own ups and downs, and when
you go back in the history of this whole region
there's a lot of history there, including
between China and Korea.
So actually we think that's a good thing and
part of this network of security that we encourage-China,
South Korea, and us all together.
Obviously North Korea isn't joining that right
now and I can well see why it's concerning
to the Chinese.
But I think you've seen in President Park
and President Xi, as well as President Obama,
as I mentioned, a real desire to join Korea-now,
South Korea I'm talking about and China, and
get over some of their previous history.
We're supporters of that.
BOIES: Do we have a red line with North Korea?
They do not yet have the capability of hitting
the United States but they're certainly working
on it.
Do we have a point at which we will not just
stand for-
CARTER: Well, we certainly have-
BOIES: -their activities?
CARTER: We certainly have a defensive plan,
but it extends beyond the Korean Peninsula
with respect to North Korea.
As I said, their behavior is unpredictable.
I would be imprudent as a secretary of defense
to assume that North Korea isn't going to
continue to make progress.
Now, we will, ourselves, and with the help
of the Chinese, try to make that less likely,
but we're taking-and we actually made this
decision several years ago to increase the
number and the capabilities of our defenses,
including our missile defenses, of the Continental
United States, of Alaska, of Hawaii.
And so we're taking steps, so we are-it definitely
has consequences for us and we're doing what
we have to do.
It's part of our investments in our posture
for the future there.
BOIES: You mentioned India, and you have certainly
personally put a lot of time and attention
into building what for us would be a very
important and relatively new, strong alliance.
You say that we may have what you characterize
as difficult negotiations over co-production
and co-development of military capability
such as fighter airplanes.
What is India going to want that we're not
going to give them?
CARTER: Well, it's just difficult in the sense
of it's business.
BOIES: And there are technology transfer issues
involved.
CARTER: There are.
There are.
In these cases I think that there are some
of those issues, but really you've got to
understand the challenges here I think are
surmountable, but they derive from history
more than they derive from today's logic.
The history goes like this: The United States
and India, for 50 years, since after Indian
independence, essentially lived apart.
India's policy was one of nonalignment in
the Cold War.
They wouldn't do with us the kinds of things
that we're doing today-together today.
To the extent they had a technology relationship-military
technology relationship with another country,
it was mostly the Soviet Union.
So their entire military industrial system
and ours grew up very differently and remain
quite different.
So you're talking about taking two things
that are really quite different and trying
to match them up and make them work together.
And a lot of the difficulties that-in just
making the U.S.-India defense relationship
go forward are simply of that nature.
But there's no difficulty in principle either
with the idea, in our minds, that India is
an enduring partner, or in their minds their
willingness to work with us, although in a
way that retains their independence, which
is important.
BOIES: Right.
CARTER: Of course we don't have any problem
with that.
When it gets down to issues of co-production
and co-development, I mean, there you get
into, you know, situations where it's not
just technology but these are American companies.
And we don't do the negotiations for those
companies; they do them themselves.
But, you know, my job is to make those kind
of negotiations less difficult by making sure
that this 50 years of history is overcome
in the bureaucratic and administrative reflex
sense, and that the tremendously bright opportunity
of this huge place, a billion people, and
the United States in decades to come-as I
said, I use the word "destiny."
I see there's no question about where the
United States-India relationship is going.
We can control and influence the pace, and
I want to do that.
BOIES: My personal view is that you will go
down as the most effective multi-tasker in
the history of secretaries of defense.
(Laughter.)
CARTER: I used to say that.
BOIES: And in that regard, you have started
consortiums with Silicon Valley; you've enlisted
Eric Schmidt to chair a committee that will
do a lot of future looking.
Just the other day you were at MIT announcing
a consortium to develop fabrics-
CARTER: Yeah.
BOIES: -that will be of military use.
Tell us about these innovative projects and
what we can look forward to seeing.
CARTER: Well, one of the strengths-you know,
what makes ours the finest fighting force
the world has ever known?
Well, first it's our people.
And I have to tend to that so that 10 years,
20 years, 30 years from now-it's an all-volunteer
force.
We don't make anybody do this.
We continue to attract and retain great people.
But the second thing that makes-has made the
American military great over decades and decades
is technology.
In the old days, in the old Sputnik days,
much of the technology of consequence for
military purposes was born in the United States
and actually under the United States government.
We still do a lot.
We're spending $72 billion on research and
development this year.
But we're still-that's more than twice what
the major tech companies combined spent on
R&D in a year.
So were still a big dog, but it's a much more
diversified, industrial and technological
landscape.
And of course, it's more international and
it's more commercial.
So if we're going to stay great in that sense,
we need to reach out.
And that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to build new bridges to what we
know is a new, innovative culture.
It's not the same as it was in the '50s, and
'60s, and '70s.
And glorious as our history is, with satellite
communications and the Internet, and all the
things that were born from defense innovation,
it's going to be different in the future.
And I need to connect with those people.
When I do so, and that's what I was up there
doing in Boston in this area of fabrics, which
may sound like a niche, but it's not really
if you think about being able to wear clothing
that will be your batteries, charge your batteries,
and make it difficult to detect and see you,
and regulate your temperature whether it's
cold or-all these things are now possible.
So it's just one-and, by the way, one that
is of importance to the economy more generally.
So where I can create that unity in a new
way, I really need to do that.
I owe that to my successor and my successor's
successor.
I find, when I do that, that the tech community
of all kinds-it's not just Silicon Valley
and it's not just tech-tech, you know, the
IT.
It's sort of biotech.
Boston is a big hub of that.
Manufacturing technology, which is the purpose
of the manufacturing institute that we funded
up in the Boston area, which is number eight
of eight that we've done of that kind.
I find that the innovators of America are
very welcoming of that.
And they-first of all, they recognize that
it's serious business.
Security-it's not a game.
And they recognize that.
And secondly, these are people who like to
do things that matter.
And protecting our people and leaving a better
world for our children, that really matters.
So I find the uptake is really high.
And it's just-and you know, every time I'm
doing something in family programs, women
in the military, and so forth, they say, why
are you doing these things?
I'm doing them because I want to make sure
that we remain the finest fighting force the
world has ever known.
To that, I need to keep up with how generations
change, how technology changes, and make sure
that, as I constantly tell our people, we're
thinking outside of our five-sided box of
the Pentagon.
(Laughter.)
BOIES: I would like to open for questions.
Please state your name and your affiliation.
And please, try to keep your question shorter
and more to the point than mine.
(Laughter.)
Yes, sir.
Q: George Schwab, National Committee on American
Foreign Policy.
Thank you very much, Mr. Secretary.
I wonder, in your deterrence-in our deterrence
policy, what role does Taiwan play?
CARTER: Well, Taiwan is a good trading partner
of the United States.
Our policy there derives from-and this gets
down into the sort of lore of past times,
but it still is the basis of our policy, has
been for decades and it's worked-goes back
to the so-called three communiques between
the United States and China, which settled
between us the issue of was Taiwan-was there
one China, and so forth.
And that policy has been established now-it
goes back to several administrations.
It's been sustained through that time, and
by successive governments of Taiwan, and by
successive governments in China as a good
thing.
And the other is the Taiwan Relation Act,
which instructs us, and me as the secretary
of defense, to maintain the capability to
assist Taiwan in its own defense.
So we do that.
But in the main, our policy derives from the
three communiques.
And that situation has been a peaceful one
now for a number of decades.
And if you go back to the 1950s, you know,
you will remember, there was a real prospect
of conflict over Taiwan.
So it's an example, if you like, of something
that takes a long time.
And, of course, it hasn't been landed yet.
But we've kept the peace in a way that has
allowed Taiwan to certainly develop, in its
own way, and kept it peaceful, in the peace
between the United States and China and Taiwan
and others in the region.
So that's the story.
BOIES: I'm going to take two questions.
Yes, sir, in the front.
And yes, sir, in the middle.
Here.
Q: I don't have a microphone, so I'll speak
loudly.
BOIES: You need a microphone, sir.
Q: David Rivkin, president of the International
Bar Association.
I applaud your work with India.
You didn't mention at all how it might impact
our relations with Pakistan, which are so
important for many other reasons.
So I was wondering if you could talk about
that-
CARTER: Sure.
Q: -for just a minute.
Sure.
Well-
BOIES: Before you do, can I get another question
in?
CARTER: Yeah.
BOIES: You in the middle.
Sir.
Q: Secretary, Jason Sherman from Inside Defense.
As the department thinks about this region,
I wonder if you could say a word or two about
a relatively new entity stood up in the Office
of Secretary of Defense called the China Strategic
Initiative, about its composition, its role
in policymaking, and planning and budgeting.
Thank you.
CARTER: OK.
Well, first of all, with respect to Pakistan,
that also is an important security partner;
a whole lot of issues, of which counterterrorism
looms largest.
And we work with the Pakistanis all the time
on that.
It's long past-we're long past the point in
U.S. policymaking where we look at the India-Pakistan
dyad as the whole story for either one of
them.
We have much more to do with India today than
has to do with Pakistan.
There's important business with respect to
Pakistan, but we have much more-a whole global
agenda with India, an agenda that covers all
kinds of issues.
With respect to Pakistan, once again, totally
different.
We have a big set of issues having to do with
the border with Afghanistan, where we continue
to operate; with terrorism, both on the territory
of Pakistan and also obviously cross-border
into Afghanistan, including affecting U.S.
service members there.
And so I'm sure I'll be asked about it in
India.
But the first thing one needs to say, from
an American policy point of view, these are
both respected partners and friends.
They find themselves in very different situations.
And the days are gone when we only deal with
India as the other side of the Pakistan coin,
or Pakistan as the other side of the India
coin.
I know that there are those in India and Pakistan
who are still glued to that dyad way of thinking.
But the United States put that behind us some
time ago.
BOIES: And then the question about China.
CARTER: Well, I don't know specifically what
is being referred to there, but we have a
number of ways I've described-they weren't
described today, but the things that we're
doing to underwrite our ambition to have a
stronger relationship with China in the military-to-military
area.
Q: (Off mic)-but it's a red team that-
CARTER: I believe that's possible.
Q: It's a red team at OSD.
It's the China Strategic Initiative?
CARTER: Well, I'm afraid I don't know.
There are lots of teams around, and particularly
ones looking at China.
So I don't know what this particular one is.
BOIES: My cheap watch-
CARTER: I hope it's doing good work.
(Laughter.)
BOIES: My cheap watch does not match the clock.
How are we for time?
We've got-do we have time for more questions?
MR.
: I'm really sorry.
We got to-
BOIES: OK.
We have a hard stop, I am very sorry to say.
Mr. Secretary, thank you so much.
CARTER: Thank you.
It's good to be with you.
Appreciate it.
(Applause.)
Good to be with you.
(END)